In Odessa when someone’s house settles oddly
or their water line breaks
or their pet goes missing
It’s not uncommon for them to curse
those goddamn catacombs
Underneath Odessa is the largest catacomb system
in the world!
with over a 1000 miles of unexplored tunnels
and a total length of 2500 kilometers
That is more than the distance from Odessa to Paris
From the end of the 1700s on people have been
mining and quarrying limestone out of the catacombs
both legitimately and illegitimately
the catacombs also became the preferred hideout of
eccentrics, smugglers, criminals of any kind
during the wars, especially world war II
huge groups of soldiers lived in these catacombs for over a year
in the 1960s they became home to catacomb explorers
every year the founding catacombs exploration group called “Poisk" or “the search”
performs a huge mapping expedition
they take forty people below ground
they cook dinner down there, they spend four days underneath the surface of Odessa
and they map an unexplored part of the catacombs
but it’s slow work, it’s ten, twenty, thirty kilometers at a time
which at thirty kilometers a year, they should be finished in about thirty years
that catacombs of course, for these explorers
are dangerous places
in 2005 a group of Ukrainian teenagers went into the catacombs to celebrate New Years
they were hanging out, they were drinking
and a young girl named Masha wandered off
and they couldn’t find her
in fact the catacombs are so large,
they didn’t retrieve her body for two years
the catacombs are a problem for Odessa
people are channeling their sewage directly into the catacombs
which makes exploring them potentially extremely gross
that sewage weakens the limestone
and can cause the tunnels to cave in
left to their own devices they are all going to slowly dissolve
taking down the city of Odessa with them...